hannover damals luca letztlich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video vor
zwei monaten so ein video hochgeladen in
dem ich gesagt habe wie findet in den
kommentaren ein kommentar von mir
angewöhnt das für eine geschichte
schreiben sollen also frei in einem
kommentar schreibt anhand von objektiven
kommentar und wir versuchen die längste
größere youtube kommentar geschichte
aller zeiten zu machen und das ist sehr
sehr viele kommentare angekommen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht hat sich
in dem heutigen video einfach mal diese
kommentare durch die und wir uns quasi
anschauen weil es ja schon so mit einer
der längsten youtube kommentare die idee
gab also hier ist das video das ich
dabei hochgeladen habe wir sehen hilfen
kommen 20.000 lies okay ihr wird auf
jeden fall wieder eskaliert leute wir
machen das jetzt einfach motiven wir
noch mal und findet ihr unter diesem
video ist jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
runter die kommentartext infineon
kommentar von mir und ich fange wieder
eine geschichte an und ihr müsst das
ganze wieder fortsetzen
damals hab ich geschrieben kommen wir
schreiben eine geschichte war einmal ein
blogger die beiden top kommentare
darunter haben auf 4203 1900 liegt er
richtig geile und der spi mit vollem
mund aber ich würde sagen kriegen kann
man auch alle kommentare anzeigen und
jetzt stürzen wir uns in die großen und
ähnlichen seiten der youtube kommentare
es war einmal ein luca der geschickt hat
er geschickt hat es ist kann man zählen
leipzig hat zu deren eine uni da hat
einer auf jeden fall das prinzip war
schon meine damen ist der sinn dabei ist
er einer etwas schreiben der andere muss
dann quasi fortsetzen das heißt er
gepflegt hatte man muss auch mal über
schreiben während er eine wurf gegeben
wurde im zusammenhang mit kicken ist
jetzt nicht so sinnvoll
der an eine uni die er brauchte roller
gut alles gut
er war ein voller youtuber der ist dumm
er spielte basketball und dachte er
kickte ein pony luca ging in wald und
wand macht der dreh war ein video
ermordet ihr wert hat das leute habt ihr
da fragen sie verkraftet habt ihr das
prinzipien wie kapiert der spitze aber
er hatte keine lust bei youtube zu
machen wer geht noch runde da er hatte 1
0 cm schwanz der schaute gerne bob der
baumeister dating auf toilette der waren
der luca war sehr normal aus lucka
musste zu wachsen weil der macht über
video der schock wie eine bombe
politik kann unter diesem video
schreiben deinen kopf und einfache
geschichte irgendwie an und das mit
einem ganz normalen waffen ihr müsst
dann einen anderen weg schreiben nicht
meinen komisch
übrigens kommt diese tab hier am
effekten in der band kommt ein
werbevideo für den service link kommt
dann nicht nur diese camp in den shop
sondern es kommen auch noch die andere
produkte meine ideen ihre produkte
bieten einzigartig was ich bisher so
teilweise noch gar nicht gesehen hat an
designs auch das heißt sie haben dieses
jahr über zwei familien erweckten halten
sommerkollektion und einmal damit an den
ersten wolken wo dann wieder so ein paar
andere sachen kommen werden maria leute
linken schon in der beschreibung im
ersten sechsten ich weiß dauert noch
zwei monate aber könnte schon mal mit
dem kalender streichen
wahrscheinlich auch wieder zu 1500
zitierte sicher arbeitet weiter mit dem
kommentar der hatte ein alpaka und
nistet sich in die hose und packte sich
auch ein er war echt geil der hitliste
der gerne pizza markt der macht keine
videos der in den ball lief mit grant
foster
wieso sollte ich bei allem respekt in
den wald laufen mit krankhafter und er
war ein toller youtuber denn nur ein
bisschen dumm war der war sehr klug okay
die beiden kommentare einfach sollten
wir untereinander aber ich bin sehr froh
bei der wasserkraft neun leichen der
fünf like und dann sah er
er fühlte sich trat und er wohnte im
wald lebenden verwandten weit alltag ja
gerne kommt nacht und ein einer galerie
wo ich habe meine verstehen die menschen
gern pott und wohnt in einer einer
galerie kommen wir jetzt zu den besten
kommentare wirklich unter diese
komplette reihe hier gepostet wurde
allerdings unter merkel noch jeden fall
das bringt die komplett verstanden der
planung und vor allem hat er auch
richtig bock einer ganzen sache es
handelt sich hierbei um keinen anderen
kommentatoren öl de luca komme auch er
war gerade beschäftigt mit einem erbe
eines tages mit raub und und luca war im
wald der youtube star ist er machte
gerade bei wie immer mega trude
videoteam reader und fand dort eine
socke und saß auf dem stuhl und darüber
was nach er ging auf einlass irgendwie
das prinzip verstanden
ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht lange
überlegen um dieses video hochladen soll
wird gerade den habe ich natürlich
hochgeladen aber ich bin ihnen dieser
zeit enttäuscht ich enttäuscht war
falsch rübergebracht aber ich wollte die
kommentare doch wohl nicht angucken von
diesem video wieder er hatte einen lasse
etwas weißes kommt mit kampf kuchen vor
king live
wer waren süß und süchtig nach kuchen
liebe dich der immer war beliebt er war
einen psychiater einen youtube kanal der
eine youtuber irre der waldbäume
schlagen doch die schmeckte niveau etwas
findet jeden tag gegessen hat der
mayonnaise auch als instrumenten nutzt
alter könnt ihr alle nicht schreiben die
firma twitter der sturm davonmacht
geschlagen wurde und verpackte hat ein
betrieb viele klickbare der innfloh
gefallen ist liegen in walding
innenstadt erwartet um dass er der beste
der wurde die leute eure kommentare
jedoch sehr wohl größten für dich nicht
gelesen die freude machen
darunter hat nur gewinnen da sehr viele
kommentare tatsächlich unter geschrieben
oder auch mein ende hier als wir gucken
uns immer noch ein paar kommentare an
die hier drunter gepostet wurden dicker
hat 174 live luca ich liebe deine video
112 ist mein lieblings youtuber luca 21
bietet einen deutsch nachhilfe an der
englische wort als geschrieben hat luca
ich muss dir das wichtige sagen erklärt
das war auch schon vom video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe das hat sich
irgendwie gefallen ich dachte zuerst ein
paar andere kommentare ankommen aber
irgendwie haben wir alles richtig
verstanden wenn er glaubt video hier
trotzdem gefallen hat er damals hätten
leiter und bei sind leider wird die
torte meisten krankenzahl stefanie
gesagt aber hey leute lupu wir schaffen
das nur ich hab ne total kaputte kamera
schon in mainz als alleiniges mikro hin
an das ist schon mit sekundenkleber hier
geklebt und mit gummibändern fixiert
jetzt wohnen in die kommentare und
antwortet wieder auf meinen kommentar
vielleicht ist meine eigenständige
geschichte schaffen können und ja dann
findet das überfall könnte mich auch
hier oben abonnieren dahin nämlich eine
smiley eingeblendeten darauf wie könnt
ihr mich nämlich abonnieren so wie
vorhin schon gesagt habe da oben findet
ebenfalls meinen stock eingeblendet die
gedacht ersten wechsel gibt merchandise
unter anderem halt lieber kaffee anderer
teil habe ich mein land gezeigt und die
hunde sind doch nicht sein